desde el Ministerio de relaciones
exteriores en Guatemala se ha informado
de este jueves y sin especificar un
número que no será uno sino varios los
centros de preselección de migrantes que
se abran en este país centroamericano se
abrirán en la ruta de tránsito que
conecta a Honduras con México aquí en
Guatemala por la vía del Atlántico y la
vía Panamericana y uno de los puntos
clave que menciona la cancillería es que
pese a que Guatemala es un corredor de
miles de migrantes de diferentes
nacionalidades de Sudamérica de
Centroamérica Haití Cuba países
africanos en esta primera etapa de plan
piloto que se sostendrá con Estados
Unidos Únicamente se beneficiará y se
Tratará a los nacionales guatemaltecos
serán ellos los nacionales guatemaltecos
quienes tengan la oportunidad de
solicitar migrar hacia los Estados
Unidos por vías legales y los
prerrequisitos serán los mismos con Los
criterios que se estudian las
solicitudes de asilo en Estados Unidos
uno de los puntos claves será entonces
la reunificación familiar teniendo en
cuenta que en Estados Unidos hay cerca
de 4 millones de guatemaltecos en un
país de 18 millones de habitantes Así
que muchos deberán demostrar que tienen
familiares con ciudadanía o con
residencia legal y es por eso que cada
día desde este país centroamericano
salen más de 1.500 personas con rumbo a
cumplir el sueño americano